estoy aquí en des mosses puntocom que es
una calculadora gráfica en línea y el
objetivo de este vídeo es explorar cómo
ocurren los cambios en las funciones
cómo se desplazan las cosas hacia la
derecha o hacia la izquierda o cómo se
mueven hacia arriba y hacia abajo y lo
que vamos a empezar a hacer es una
gráfica muy simple f x es igual a x al
cuadrado eso se ve como lo esperamos
pero ahora pensemos en cómo podemos
moverla hacia arriba o hacia abajo bueno
podemos pensar que para cambiarla solo
tenemos que hacer que el valor de fx sea
más grande así que podemos sumar un
valor y eso aparece que la cambió en 1 a
lo que era f x antes le estamos sumando
1 así que la gráfica cambia hacia arriba
en 1 eso es bastante intuitivo si
restamos 1 o en realidad vamos a restar
3 fíjense la movió hacia abajo el
vértice estaba justo aquí en 0 0 ahora
está en 0 menos 3
así que la movió hacia abajo y podemos
configurar un control deslizante aquí
para
está un poco más claro así que
simplemente voy a reemplazar esto con la
variable que dejen de borrar esta
pequeña cosa aquí este subíndice que se
puso ahí
entonces aquí es donde podemos agregar
un control deslizante para acá y eso nos
permite establecer el valor de acá así
que aquí acá es igual a 1
esto es x al cuadrado más 1 fíjense que
lo hemos cambiado hacia arriba y si
aumentamos el valor de acá fíjense cómo
cambia la gráfica hacia arriba y a
medida que disminuimos el valor de acá
si cae 0 estamos de vuelta en nuestro
vértice que está justo en el origen y a
medida que disminuimos el valor de acá
desplazamos nuestra gráfica hacia abajo
y eso es bastante intuitivo porque
estamos sumando o restando esa cantidad
a x al cuadrado así que cambie el valor
y lo desplaza hacia arriba o hacia abajo
pero como nos movemos hacia la izquierda
o hacia la derecha lo que es interesante
es cambiar a la izquierda oa la derecha
podemos reemplazar nuestra x con una x
menos algo así que vamos a ver cómo
podría funcionar así que voy a
reemplazar nuestra x con una x menos 1
que piensas que va a pasar crees que
esto va a cambiar en 1 a la derecha o en
una a la izquierda
así que vamos a poner el uno bueno eso
es interesante antes nuestro vértice
estaba en 0 0 ahora nuestro vértice está
en 10 así que reemplazar nuestra x con
una x menos 1 en realidad cambiamos 1 a
la derecha ahora porque eso tiene
sentido bueno una manera de pensar en
esto es que antes de reemplazar nuestra
x con una x menos 1 el vértice era
cuando estábamos elevando al cuadrado a
ahora para elevar al cuadrado a 0 el
cuadrado 0 ocurre cuando x es igual a 1
cuando x es igual a 1 ac es uno menos
uno obtiene cero y entonces es cuando
estás elevando al cuadrado a cero así
que tiene sentido que tengas un
comportamiento similar de la gráfica en
el vértice cuando x es igual a uno como
antes tenías cuando x es igual a 0 y
para ver cómo se puede generalizar
pongamos otra variable aquí y vamos a
añadir un control deslizante para h y
luego podemos ver que cuando h es 0 y
acá es cero nuestra función en realidad
es sólo x al cuadrado
y luego se aumenta estamos reemplazando
nuestra x con x menos un valor mayor eso
está cambiando hacia la derecha y a
medida que h disminuye cuando se vuelve
negativo eso hace que se desplace hacia
la izquierda ahora aquí h es igual a
menos 5 normalmente no verás x menos -5
verás eso escrito como x 5
así que si reemplazas tus x con una x +
5 en realidad todo se desplazará 5
unidades hacia la izquierda y por
supuesto podemos cambiar todo al mismo
tiempo así que aquí estamos cambiando
hacia arriba y luego podríamos volver a
nuestro cambio horizontal neutral
entonces podemos cambiar hacia la
derecha de esa manera y todo lo que
hicimos justo ahora lo hicimos con la
función x al cuadrado como nuestra
función central pero podrías hacerlo con
todo tipo de funciones podrías hacerlo
con una función de valor absoluto
hagamos valor absoluto eso siempre es
divertido así que en lugar de elevar al
cuadrado todo este asunto vamos a tener
un valor absoluto aquí de modo que voy a
poner 1
absoluto y ahí lo tienes puedes empezar
déjame hacer estas dos variables igual a
cero para que la gráfica sea fx es igual
al valor absoluto de x pero digamos que
quieres cambiarlo de modo que este punto
que tenemos aquí que está en el origen
se mueva al punto menos cinco menos
cinco que está justo ahí entonces lo que
harías es reemplazar tu x con x + 5 o
harías que esta variable h valiera menos
5 justo aquí porque fíjense que si
reemplazas tu h con un -5 dentro del
valor absoluto tendrás x + 5 y luego si
quieres cambiarlo sólo reduce el valor
de k y si quieres bajarlo en 5 se reduce
en 5 y podrías obtener algo así así que
te invito a que vayas a decimos puntocom
prueba esto por ti mismo y juega con
estas funciones para darte una idea de
cómo y por qué las cosas cambian hacia
arriba o hacia abajo cuando agregas una
constante y porque las cosas se mueven
hacia la izquierda o hacia la derecha
cuando reemplaza sus x con x
en este caso x h pero realmente podría
ser x menos algún tipo de constante